I want to though before we have Barbara
play do you mind playing okay I know you
know you will I want to read the
requirement by probably the third most
renowned virtuoso that ever lived the
most intelligent man
Ferruccio Busoni who celebrated his
hundredth birthday the death of his
recently a hundred years and this is
what he says this is the an article he
writes the requirements for a great
virtuoso and this is unbelievable
because the man had an idealism that no
one could come up to but he writes it
anyway a great virtuoso must first of
all be a great technician further the
great virtuoso must necessarily have an
unusual intelligence and culture he must
be widely educated in music and
literature in all matters affecting
human existence as well the virtue also
must also have character if no one does
if one of these requisites is missing
even one for him the deficiency will be
apparent in every phrase he plays then
add to that feeling
temperament imagination poetry and
finally that personal magnetism would
sometimes enables the player to inspire
4000 people strangers whom chances
brought together with one and the same
state of feeling with one of this there
is still the presence of mind you must
have some just never could really have
that presence of mind to play in public
and some you have to also have that that
ability to control your mood in mence
Lehrer tating conditions the acoustic
could be bad the piano could be horrible
the ability to rouse the attention even
of the public and then finally to forget
the public
shall one add the sealing of form
structure style and of good taste and
originality yes the virtue also must be
a quick change artist from Bach
metaphysician to Mozart gallantry to
Beethoven God knows what and scriabin Z
rata sysm and these are all such worlds
apart no actor could ever have to I
think you'll agree be a gypsy enlist and
then be some poet initial panic sir it
is incredible what is demanded of the
the piano and that is one of the things
that we're trying to get clear what I
love about barbers playing is that she
takes from a pianist point of the risks
that so few and when we were talking you
said that's one of the things today that
that the young pianist Aires is so
terrified of every note and you said
where are the risks want to say a little
on that yeah it's just what I think this
is where toto
the former pianist you could recognize
him there were much more individuals as
now and they were taking risks because
risk is all about life it's all about
pianist is all about arts and nowadays
many of these young pianists because of
all these competitions they are so
scared to hit one wrong note so it's
also because of the DVDs and the CDs
they are aiming for perfection and
perfection is going to be the end of art
and of calipari
no the true I believe the true
definition of virtuosity is that it
enables the artist to take the risk to
play with abandon to really go to a
higher place to get under the notes to
get beyond the nose so you can touch the
souls of the audience that's that's what
the purpose of its freedom that's the
purpose was ask and you see a list is so
fantastic because you see there is the
first manifestation of a middle-class
public that he sees and he knows that
these people must be conquered through
art they didn't understand popular music
there were not you know there was
another world and what he did was this
genius from Chopin on was to teach us
what the piano could do under Beethoven
and under Mozart in the classical
composers it was still a developing and
timid instruments and it could fall
apart but by lists time you had the iron
frame which was invented by an American
in Boston that would become part of a
Chickering company and this without this
iron frame you see Spears where
technology and art really work we'd
never be able to have had these
transcendental etudes one of the pieces
that Barbara is it's not even an
affection or love
it's an adoration which is higher than
love and it's it's Melissa nada and her
DVD actually analyzes this drastic and
intellectual atiba what a work but
within it is also the Grand Manor the
Grand Manor is a part of what virtuoso
is which also is not some stuntman
virtuosity is a very different thing to
be so respected and it's so beyond the
machine because it comes from the
humanity of the most important thing the
human being has that
and the grand manner of playing a great
many people speak of it as though it
were the special manifestation of a
special period of time like crinolines
our stuff boxes know the Grand Manor did
not come in at one special date and go
out at another the Grand Manor is very
simply a grand manner and I hope a few
of us still have it in us a manner of
playing which forms itself upon grand
concepts make such concepts personal by
grand enthusiasms and paint as pianistic
pictures in bold brilliant grand strokes
that's a rhetorical thing it is a matter
of personal conviction personal
inspiration personal idealism all of
this we heard in boos oniy they're
talking about what the pianist needs
personal thought the mere typical
representative of this modern day seem
less concerned with a free outpouring of
generous enthusiasms then with the
practical means of achieving some goal
it is not considered smart to give
unfettered expression to one's deepest
emotions one must be nonchalant and
practical we've never heard of Louis
Marchand but he was the greatest of all
French Organists and he came to Germany
because he had heard that the greatest
organist in Germany was bought and he
liked competitions it was the same then
people were competitive and he was going
to and there was an arrangement not in
life set but in Dresden that they would
be playing a competition and there's a
wonderful church by his organ in the
search by Silverman his friend organ
builder and this man got up very early
in the morning to Spock was travelling
from right second improvising in play
and he heard ma and the contest
never happened
he hightailed himself back to Parry and
so Bach didn't have a chance to beat him
but the point is is that Bach was the
greatest virtue also of the organ that
ever lived and probably very close to
the harpsichord and certainly must have
been a beauty in the clavichord
you